new research shows the virus that causes
the common cold
can help our bodies stop coronavirus
from spreading
scientists at glasgow university found
that human rhinovirus
triggers an immune response blocking
covid19 from replicating in cells in our
respiratory tracts it raises the
possibility
that catching a cold could provide some
protection against the
virus professor pablo mercier is part of
the team behind the research and we can
speak to him now
professor thanks very much indeed for
being with us i've done my best to
explain
uh what you've found but i wonder if if
you can tell us a little bit more about
it
well thank you for having me you
explained it really well so
what uh we studied and we published over
a year ago that um human respiratory
viruses interact
both at the epidemiological level that
is at the population level
and at the individual patient level and
the most notable example of those
interactions was
between rhinovirus the agent of the
common code
and influenza a virus so we wonder
whether
there could be interactions between
rhinovirus and
starscope too so in the absence of
epidemiological data due to all the
diagnostic efforts towards detecting
sarskoff 2
plus the effect of the intervention
measures that are
stopping the spread of natural
transmission of respiratory viruses
what we decided to do was to perform
experiments but we did these experiments
using a highly sophisticated
cell cultures and these are cell
cultures of
a human tracheobronchial cells that are
differentiated in a way that
mimic to great extent the lining of our
respiratory tract
what we did was then infect these
cultures
with rhinovirus and with sarskoff ii
and observed that in the presence of
rhinovirus starscoff2 couldn't replicate
in the respiratory epithelium and
we did this in different ways infecting
first with starscope 2 leaving it for 24
hours and then
infecting with rhinovirus and we
observed a similar effect
and then we carry the carried on doing
further experiments to try to understand
the mechanism behind this and what we
show is that rhinovirus triggers a
transient
innate immune response which is mediated
by the interf the by interferon
and that blocks the replication of a
starscope too
then to try to understand the relevance
of this because
our work was experimental uh we
collaborated with imperial college
london and
they use mathematical models to try to
determine what the epidemiological
impact of these
interactions could be and what the
mathematical models show is that
in when you have high prevalence of
rhinovirus
common codes that would cause a decrease
in the number of new covet 19 cases
so so effectively a rhinovirus is a
relatively selfish virus and
and it wants you to itself it says
there's no room for anything else
how in real life in the real world
outside
of laboratory could this be used to try
and reduce case numbers
well the the best tool we have to reduce
case numbers is without any doubt
the vaccines okay so this will be the
main
barrier for a starscope to
to spread in the population then on top
of that
what we think as an additional barrier
these virus will have to compete
with other respiratory viruses and we
have quite a few respiratory viruses
that circulate commonly
in the population influenza a b
respiratory incision virus para
influenza viruses etc
because of the measures that we've been
taking though professor over
the course of the last year with social
distancing with increased
hand hygiene for example have we seen
rates of those common colds of influenza
falling
well uh yes the what we have seen
is that the all the intervention
measures that have been put in place
have uh reduce significantly the
transmission of
most respiratory viruses yes
a common cold we we all accept it it's
part of
life um it's also relatively short-lived
isn't it
does that then mean it only gives
protection for a short period of time
that's correct
so this this innate immune response is
is a response that is triggered by the
cells
when when they get infected or when they
sense a vital viral infection
and this is a short-lived response the
the effect that we
think might happen at the population
level is based on the high level the
high transmissibility of
of the the common cold virus okay
and fascinating talking to you who would
have thought we'd be embracing the
common
cole but professor pablo mercier thank
you very much
indeed thank you